on avait accueilli sur le plateau
francis lalanne et sur notre plateau il
avait chanté une chanson pour rendre
hommage aux gendarmes un nobel tram on
regarde tout de suite l'hommage de
francis lalanne parce qu'on voulait
absolument vous montrer parce que
c'était hors antenne et sur le plateau
vraiment il ya une émotion
extraordinaire avec tous les
chroniqueurs donc regarder c'est trente
secondes mais juste vraiment je pense
que ça va vous toucher regarder francis
était venu après l'émission pour nous
faire non voulez vous le montrez ce soir
regardez on se retrouve au plateau c'est
parti
et sur la photo
il sourit
tant d'autres est connu comme lui le
même sort le même drame
et nous le voudrions
hélas
vers son touch
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
les mélomanes
[Applaudissements]